ja da ist bei uns alexander gauland zum
interview holland gestern das war so
eine art vermächtnis rede die sie
gehalten haben für die partei als
scheidender parteivorsitzender langsam
ein bisschen erzählen sie auch eine art
bewährungshelfer für ihre ex partei die
cdu glauben sie denn an ein bündnis mit
der cdu in absehbarer zeit von
absehbarer zeit kann ich geredet sein
dafür gibt es jetzt immer noch zu viel
in der cdu die das sich gar nicht
vorstellen können aber ich frage mich
wenn was kommen wird links spd und grüne
zusammen gehen dann hat die cdu keine
option mehr
wenn sie die macht nicht endgültig
verlieren will muss sie für eine
bürgerliche mehrheit eintreten und nun
daran habe ich erinnert er verfolgte
tino keller ist gestern gewählt worden
als ihr nachfolger
wenn sich die ganze wahl gestern die
beiden vorsitzenden die stellvertreter
ansehen sind sie zufrieden mit dem
wieder parteitag gewählt hat ja ich bin
sehr zufrieden das ist auch ausgewogen
jetzt was die flügel die
positionierungen der afg angeht das ist
eine ausgewogen vor allen dingen können
sie das mache sie klein geschrieben und
ich groß geschrieben nicht sagen dass
die partei nach rechts gerückt ist das
heißt es zeigt sich dass qualität sich
durchsetzt und das ist gestern geschehen
und das finde ich sehr gut
der flügel das hat man gehört jetzt
gestern abend hatte morgens aber
unzufrieden mit dem wie das abgelaufen
ist werden die jetzt entschädigt
kompensiert bei der wahnsinn beisitzern
das weiß ich nicht aber flügel
unzufrieden ist das müssen sie die flüge
vertreter fragen und entschädigung das
gibt es im bad auf dem parteitag nicht
setzen sich die leute durch von denen
die partei das gefühl hat dass sie gut
sind und einen beitrag leisten können da
gibt es keine entschädigung sie können
auch nicht jemanden entgegensetzen der
vielleicht nicht gut ist und dann wird
er gewählt als entschädigung das geht
nicht
nach den ereignissen gestern bei der spd
könnten ja neuwahlen demnächst passieren
die afg da gut vorbereitet und werden
sie sich auch im bundestagswahl
entsprechend einsetzen
ich werde mich natürlich in der
bundestagswahl entsprechend einsetzen
und vorbereitet sind wir auch aber so
recht glaube ich noch nicht an die
neuwahlen weil ich mir nicht weil ich
nicht weiß wen die spd dann als
spitzenkandidat aufstellen will das neue
duo kennt ja niemand von daher sehe ich
das noch mit gewisser gelassenheit sind
denn die neuen parteivorsitzenden auch
die spitzenkandidaten für die
bundestagswahl
das weiß ich nicht weil der asd absolut
bei der afd
das weiß ich nicht das wird die partei
bestimmt das kann ich ihnen heute nicht
sagen gut dass wenn wir abwarten
alexander gauland hier im interview bei
phoenix herzlichen dank dass sie dabei